mit face sei die sollte das iphone denn
eigentlich zum sichersten mobiltelefonen
weltweit werden ein hack sollte
unmöglich sein doch genau der ist jetzt
einer vietnamesischen firma für computer
sicherheit gelungen
wie sie das geschafft haben und ob der
hack jetzt alle iphones ten unsicher
macht jetzt in science fiction herzlich
willkommen
heute aus mainz das sollte eigentlich
nicht passieren apples iphone galt
zumindest bei seiner vorstellung als
besonders sicher
der sensor für die gesichtserkennung ist
extrem ausgeklügelt und projiziert per
infrarot 30.000 messpunkte auf das
gesicht zusätzlich kann eine
aufmerksamkeits prüfung checken ob man
auch wirklich die augen auf hat und auf
das handy schaut also doppelt und
dreifach gesichert und es ist so
praktisch jetzt braucht man gar nichts
mehr zu tun ein blick genügt und das
iphone ist entsperrt war richtig cool
aber schon bei touch ein die wurden
sicherheitslücken entdeckt wer an den
fingerabdruck des richtigen fingers
kamen konnte das gerät entsperren selbst
auf fotos festgehalten fingerabdrücke
auf trinkgläsern reichten aus also nicht
100 prozent sicher aber face id sollte
sicherer sein sollte also was haben die
vietnamesen gemacht umfelds sei die zu
überlisten erstmal das iphone war mit
der maximalen sicherheitsstufe gesichert
zusätzlich zur gesichtserkennung wurde
auch die aufmerksamkeit geprüft eine
prüfung die zum beispiel verhindert dass
man jemand einfach umbringen um an die
daten zu kommen
mit dem gesicht eines toten kann das
iphone ten eigentlich nicht entsperrt
werden eigentlich dieses
sicherheitsfeature wurde von der
sicherheitsfirma intensiv geprüft nach
einigen versuchen gelang es ihnen das
iphone zu entsperren obwohl ein auge
zugedrückt war und auf dem anderen auge
ein foto des auges klebte die
aufmerksamkeits prüfung war also nicht
ganz so aufmerksam wie apple es
behauptet und dann kam der versuch mit
der maske der firma gelang es eine maske
herzustellen die in der lage war das
iphone tatsächlich zu entsperren
allerdings und jetzt können sich alle
wieder entspannt zurück lehnen es
dauerte sehr lange bis sie die maske so
angefertigt hatten dass sie auch
funktionierte immer wieder entsperrten
sie dafür das iphone mit dem gesicht der
echten person und modifizierten die
maske ein prozess der in der realität
anders als bei einem fingerabdruck nicht
funktionieren würde man bräuchte
schließlich die mitarbeit des echten
besitzers oder der besitzerin mehr ist
sicher haben will kann das iphone
übrigens auch so konfigurieren dass es
nach zehn versuchen alle daten löscht
das ergebnis ist also tatsächlich lässt
sich facetime austricksen dafür wäre
aber die mitarbeit der person nötig die
zugriff auf das iphone
war das ein komplett absurdes szenario
ist face aldi damit die sicherste
methode bisher um ein handy schnell und
einfach zu sichern also entwarnung und
ich muss auch sagen mir ist das einfach
zu sicher wenn ich morgens mit einem
aufwacht gesicht auf das handy schauer
passiert nichts
das gerät hat mich morgens noch nie
erkannt vielleicht kann er ja mal was
dran ändern
ja und jeden tag gibt es hier neues aus
wissenschaft und technik wenn ihr kein
video verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier
einen abort augen und vergesst nicht den
genau auf die glocke denn nur dann
verpasst ja auch wirklich kein video
hier geht es weiter dafür auf das video
klicken kulturschock ibm bus apple und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt an